a conservative commentator John O
Caldwell was just booted out of a
restaurant now jono happens to be black
was he booted out because he's black no
this isn't the Woolworth's lunch counter
this isn't the 1950s or 60s no
was he booted out because he's
a man
I don't think so now these days men can
go anywhere they can go to the women's
locker room they can go to the girl's
bathroom no you know why he was booted
out he was booted out
because he's conservative
yesterday as we were having
um breakfast at this particular location
which I had never been to it was the
suggestion to them to visit this
particular place one of the owners came
over to the table and told us she had
been listening to our conversation we
were not welcome there and I said to her
I said did I say something that was
triggering to you she said no she said
our our politics aren't aligned I'm one
of the owners I'm an owner here I don't
feel comfortable you have to leave so
then I stood up I walked out and so did
the rest of my group she told me that I
needed to get out of her establishment
if this was not the Jim Crow South I
couldn't tell much of a difference Ron
DeSantis said in Florida discrimination
is it not allowed and I hope that
they're going to look closely to what
happened here at this restaurant
so he's booted out because he's
conservative a lot of people are asking
how is this legal well the reason it's
legal is there's no
civil rights protection for political
point of view
you can't go go to a court and say I was
discriminated against on the basis of my
political views it's not protected the
race is protected religion is protected
sex is protected sexual orientation and
gender identity in the wake of the
Bostock decision thank you Neil Gorsuch
that is protected
but political views are not
this is a reminder that
one of the one of the big stories about
the Civil Rights Revolution is not true
the big line about the Civil Rights
Revolution and you you might consider
this a positive you might consider this
a negative you might say Well it had
some good effects but it actually had
some bad effects too is that it gets rid
of freedom of Association as an
essential part of the American political
order prior to the Civil Rights
Revolution
if you didn't want to let somebody into
your store if you didn't want to let
somebody into your hotel you didn't have
you didn't want to let somebody to your
lunch counter you didn't have to do it
and in the 1960s people looked at that
and said oh that's kind of ugly because
some people are keeping black people out
of the lunch counters and that doesn't
seem right so so we're gonna we're gonna
get rid of that and uh most people said
okay that's a good thing but there's a
cost to everything in this world and so
when you get rid of freedom of
Association
you are maybe you're improving certain
social situations
but you might be
you might be eroding some of the
principles that all Americans hold very
dear
and you might not even be totally
getting rid of freedom of Association
right now
a a black guy can't be kicked out of a
lunch counter that's a good thing
but a black guy who's a conservative can
a conservative of any stripe can be
kicked out of a lunch counter
a
a white male
could be kicked out of a public
accommodation
it has been known to happen you saw this
especially during BLM and all the George
Floyd riots people saying this is a
black space white people not allowed
here you're seeing this crop up on
universities black only dorms
black only spaces white people not
allowed
how's that legal well it's not legal by
the letter of the law but nobody's going
to enforce it
if any restaurant kicked out a lib
you know there would be a major lawsuit
and the litigant would probably win and
the way that they would win is they
would pretend that they were being
booted out for some other reason
be some lib you know with with purple
hair and crazy piercings and an antifa
shirt screaming about burning down The
Establishment you say hey lib can you
please get out of here this is you're
creating a nuisance and you know what
the lid would say the lid would say well
you're only doing this because I'm
trans or I'm a lesbian or I'm this color
or I'm that race or I'm whatever and you
know that they would win because the
system is set up that way
where there are just two tracks here if
you if you attack anything that is
conservative traditional
pushing back against the cultural
revolution
you can and usually will be punished
if you're the one pushing that
Revolution
you're good you're safe we talked about
this yesterday when Stephen King It was
inveying against Banning books
and everyone seems to think that they're
against Banning books that's not true
we ban books in this culture we ban the
most important book we ban the Bible in
public schools
well that's different
we we kick people out of our lunch
counters
if they're conservative
the daily wire we were booted out of a
restaurant we had put a a deposit down
on this restaurant to have a dinner
before our company Christmas party
and then they found out who we were and
they said you're not welcome here
you got you guys are you because you're
conservative you're not allowed into the
restaurant and our protests are big
standing up against the man was Jeremy
and Ben and Drew and a friend of Candace
was there Spencer a number of us went in
uh afterward and just had a drink they
were two cowardly to actually kick us
out but this happens okay
this sort of thing happens this this
reordering of the political order it
didn't create justice for all
it it just created an opportunity to
attack conservatives of any race if any
of any geography of any of any kind of
background if they oppose the revolution
they're going down right now head on
over to expressvpn.com Michael Knowles
show it is extremely important to
protect your online privacy with a VPN
choosing a VPN that you trust is just as
important the only VPN that I trust is
expressvpn these guys have been with the
show Almost since the very beginning I
think it's so easy I'm basically a
Luddite it's super easy to just you just
download the apps right there on your
computer on your phone on your tablet
wherever you want click one button you
are protected
expressvpn does not log your online
activity they've even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all number two the speed
expressvpn does not slow down your user
experience you can even stream HD videos
with zero buffering number three
expressvpn is super easy to use you just
click those buttons and and you're good
you're protected it's not just me saying
this Business Insider The Verge many
other Tech journals rate expressvpn the
number one VPN in the world protect
yourself with a VPN I trust use my link
expressvpn.com
michaelenoll's show today get three
months free on a one year package that's
expresvpn.com Michael Knowles show
expressvpn.com slash Michael Knowles
show
I have been banned by another University
you know every year I speak
at a number of college campuses I do
this with young Americas Foundation I've
done this for years at this point
and if I got a little more time
sometimes I'll do I don't know I could
do up to 10 schools a semester I've got
more work here at DW they don't want to
let me out I'll do I'll at least do four
or five schools a semester
well I guess I'm doing one fewer this
year because Penn State says that I'm
not coming even though the students
invited me they submitted their proposal
to the school I actually didn't know
that I had been invited to Penn State
until after they told me that I couldn't
come this is a Penn State University
Harrisburg
they claim that they have the exclusive
right to deny a campus lecture from me
yours truly
they say any event considered
potentially harmful to the public image
of Penn State Harrisburg will be
rejected me they want to ban me whom
everybody loves so can you imagine that
shocking
absolutely shocking this is illegal Penn
State is a public university they have
no right to do this the students do have
a right at this public university to
invite me to the school and what they
wanted me to speak on is my book
speechless controlling words controlling
Minds which is there we go thank you
number one National bestseller very
mainstream book it's a book on the
history and meaning of language
not exactly a bomb throwing kind of
topic is it if anything it's a little
bit dry
they said no it's too much
this could harm the image
of the University okay so so does Penn
State have any speakers come they do
who are some of the other speakers that
have come on campus recently that have
not harmed the public image of the
University well let's see we've got drag
bingo
these student engagement office and
student government uh hosted drag Bingo
they hosted an lgbtq panel hosted by mix
not Mr or Mrs or miss mix Jacob Kelly
who is a queer inclusive sex educator
that didn't harm the public image of the
University they uh it's not even that
they won't have explicitly political
events there was a lecture by Amy
Goodman of democracy now which is a far
left TV and radio program that was
totally fine so I think I figured out
what we're going to do
I'm gonna we're gonna have to reapply I
mean I didn't apply at all it was the
students who applied on my behalf so if
they're listening right now what I want
you to do
I want you to just you change my
pronouns in the application you could
instead of Mr Michael Knowles you say
mix mix Michaela Michelle Knowles and
then I'll just show up there and I'll
wear some stilettos and I'll say this is
an inclusive event and then I can give
my lecture on the history of language
and I think then everybody will it'll
totally work out right
sounds great to me they're still keeping
this up
that's a public university
it's public university last year a
Catholic University banned me I had been
invited to St Thomas University in
Minnesota they Banned Me
because I espouse Catholic dogma I
doesn't I'm not joking
because I don't think that boys can
become girls because I hold to
unchangeable Catholic beliefs on a basic
question of human nature they said I'm
not welcome at the Catholic University
not only are we booted out of the weird
liberal private schools we're booted out
of
the nominally Catholic and conservative
schools and were booted out of public
accommodations
expect more of that expect if you
haven't already expect to be in jono
Caldwell's position for the daily wires
position soon enough
freedom of Association
for them but not for us that's how it's
going to go and they are going to
ostracize us as as much as they can and
until conservatives recognize that it's
probably a little past time for us to
wield political power in in through the
same sort of processes that the left
wield political power albeit we should
do so in a just and moral way until we
recognize that as long as we just keep
saying well you know
come on this isn't fair look at this
double standard this is hypocrisy
imagine if the shoe were on the other
foot as long as we keep doing that we're
gonna lose and we're not going to get to
go to universities and which might be a
blessing in disguise and we're not going
to get to go to restaurants and we're
going to be forced to eat the bugs and
things are not going to turn out very
well at all you know what today is today
is woke Wednesday the rest of the show
continues now
there is a very
thought-provoking woke reaction that Mr
Davies and the other producers want me
to
to process give my expert analysis on
you only get that on the member segment
so to become a member today use code
Knowles to check out kwles that's
dailywire.com
use code nulls you will get two months
free on all annual plans
[Music]